it was a day scotland decided its
direction
short term and long two votes for
constituency and
region at this election with a
referendum
possibly at journey's end i voted for
greens and
the lived dams alex called hamilton why
because i didn't want the snp to get in
i voted snp
and why because i think they've done a
really good job
over the last year at clovid and
personally i'd like to see the decision
making brought
closer nicola why i think she's done a
great job throughout the pandemic
definitely overall yet why keep out the
snp
right quick you're going to give me a
few years yet though hello sheka
it's nicholas sturgeon here you hold it
or eyes i'm a bit scared of dogs
nicolas sturgeon displayed her fear of
dogs as she engaged with voters in our
glasgow south side constituency
it wasn't her only challenge on the
street in the midst of positive
interactions with members of the public
she was confronted by a rival candidate
convicted racist
jared franson fascist you are a racist
and the south side of glasgow will
reject of course they will
even the snp's opponents acknowledge it
will be the largest party
the question is how long an overall
majority in the next holyrood parliament
would strengthen the platform for a
second independence referendum
it's important because of the signal it
sends about what scots want
and that signal is also important in
terms of how it strengthens the hand of
any first minister
who then turns to the uk government and
says right well on the back of this
we want to hold another referendum
there's a building that sits
high in the center of edinburgh that was
refurbished to accommodate a scottish
parliament in 1979
only it wasn't delivered by a devolution
referendum then
its chamber never did welcome the
parliament it was designed for
42 years on they've been using it to
store the kit
for a covered safe voting exercise one
that could steer scotland towards yet
further constitutional change
at this election in the parliament that
does do devolution
the question is what does it do next
now normally there would be an overnight
count of course but because of covert
covert precautions
that's not happening this time counts
will be slower more protracted
they will take place they will start to
take place
tomorrow morning and will last for two
days we should know
the results of this scottish election by
saturday evening and the numbers
are important if nicola sturgeon is to
go to boris johnson in time
and in the context of constitutional
change
demand a second independence referendum
then to do so as the leader of a party
with a majority inside the hollywood
parliament that strengthens
her hand considerably this election
is about the event itself of course
but it's very much about the events that
fall